hello everybody and welcome back to its
dead space - okay
we're just making our way down in the
undeniably horrifying darkness of
darkness
duh I know what I'm talking about
ah two bucks
once the detonators beat fast becoming
my new favorite weapon like no joke
it is incredibly awesome like stupidly
awesome like I'm not even a lie I wish
it was epic wonder how II know he oh
[ __ ] ah gotcha
come here
now get it ha ha
I 100 not you little [ __ ]
just scream ma with you oh we're good
but what are you gonna do what do you
want what are you gonna do ha ha ha ha
ha ha I want you to load of ass
Oh Oh No get hit you give me that you go
there ah what the hell where you coming
from
get out here get out here right here
give it something to hit you ah what the
hell
how are they coming from everywhere ah
heal me what the hell no fair no fair
Oh flamethrower reload you ass bag then
burn them up yeah that's more like it
hey got him to cough up their items ah
no that's a big guy
Oh throw dead body at you did that
really hurt
really just body really you just fall
over at that oh man I'm just too awesome
for my own good just too awesome
Oh items Jimmy gets goodies I will say
one thing about these little gags they
are annoying but I should figure out how
to get them but they give up a lot of
goodies that is very very nice of them I
get all the good garden another health
care man I shouldn't have bought those
help that's how god I think about - boy
never mind I'm stupid okay anyway smack
in my way downtown well I know you don't
I'm off wonk
give me dad but take it back miss I
meant a myth don't tell me I didn't
approve the parkour I should be playing
this on hardcore I mean what the hell hi
what the hell
you can't just spawn right on me Wow
what's going on seriously
things just need to chill the eff out
when it comes to spawning everywhere
around me seriously these guys need to
chillax
I'm just exploding why they randomly
just explode whatever I don't care I'm
winning who's there here's someone see
anyone you like stuck in the vents
what oh there you are
nope hi how'd you get there Oh dramatic
music and off you wha wha a little bit
excessive don't you think all traffic
you you don't even have your explore
today huh oh look an ex-pro d-bag oh I
pressure to carry that with me now too
dangerous ah
oh are you oh you were one of those
charges even without any legs anymore
huh I got a sword thingy whatever it is
Jason what is this it's like it really
is like just a sword why would there
just be a sword laying enough I've seen
lots of oh hello
fancy whoa what the hell that's creepy
is that senior ultimen I know boom nope
waste ammo huh
because I was trusting my own strength
okay baby kind of creeping me out
starting to worry me
you all right you all right dead image
of my girlfriend in my brain come on now
huh
all right what do I switch to yeah I'll
give the line gonna try it with me it
wasn't good with those little kids
whatever you're Almighty I'll be waiting
by the show oh yeah you will
he's gonna be waiting for me
oh it's gonna be so sexy come on reload
don't what the hell ah hang about that
like how a little earner it supposed to
be safe
everybody F you put haha what the hell
that's where you get nothing but what
you deserve twitchy forever
good bye good sir oh that's view look at
that oh so pretty actually kind of ugly
looks like pollution what that that is
pretty actually is like a legitimate
humongous city sucks about the
Necromorphs and all that but whatever
their own damn fault is it their own
damn hole whose fault is it
hey demon Tiedemann this lady Dana ook
karna I don't even know that name is
Craddock oh I love the detonator I'd
love to try that gun that'd be fanciful
shut up squiggly guy stop squiggling
mandatory
full of what schematic self uh whatever
a school maybe
yeah totally there's only one way to go
I didn't baby i refugee walk me tamo
gist Oh George you ecologist why did I
trust you well you didn't have a choice
I don't trust anybody I told you that
was a cure and you came running yeah
yeah why can't everyone just leave me
alone
don't you turn and face me you're a
dangerous secret Isaac hello hello big
lift God won't leave you alone because
they're afraid you'll destroy their
marker uh-huh after all you did build it
I'm talking about that makes sense well
that's why we brought you here to build
markers for us to spread glorious
convergence to the entire galaxy okay
you people are unbelievable give me the
[ __ ] Karen let me go yeah do that
when i cue you Isaac
we need that precious little light of
yours just the way it is
this is why you don't trust everyone at
all everybody mean stasis the last thing
we want is vain to die for it see oh hey
and he dies and he dies and then I don't
get hit at all
ha ha ha awesome I do he he
other Z give me some e action
I love me mashing some e you couldn't
think of a more difficult one to match
how about the spacebar or something
don't match any there we go
oh like a boss not even a scratch on me
so uh hey how's it going there friend
haha quick time events oh boy yellow [ __ ]
yellow yellow [ __ ]
yeah 'fuffling suck your arms Elvis
coming out there buddy
ha ha what's wrong as you get out warm
tan out get out Oh got ya Oh Oh you to
set out oh hello rip Ron Ronnie Ronnie
run running away I know not a [ __ ] oh
that's not good
oh hello welcome back oh [ __ ]
uh ow okay this I've no idea what's
happening
whatever it is it's action-packed and
full of explosions okay I don't see
yellow are those explosives I'm f stuck
you aah
full of explosion well I just happen to
land inside what the hell just happened
Chapter six haha well hello Billy
I think are you there Kiki yes I'm here
I can you Billy it's not over at least
yeah not yet we we build it we can tear
it down are you even the marker in the
government sector government sector but
we have to move now
now now now because time is running out
for me right yep
trust the crazy guy that seems like good
idea I want to make a point I don't
trust anyone
ah single person so why should I trust
these a-holes
Oh back in the apartments again how the
heck did I get back here really how how
the heck did I get back here
I mean I was out in space and there was
an explosion everything went boom
everywhere and then Ulsan I land back in
the apartments ask me uh-huh
okay well aren't you crazies when aliens
start attacking does everyone just like
candles start writing on the walls
this looks good oh is this the same
place this is the same place I was
someone filled it with candles with that
I wish I could I wish I had the key for
this language and I can tell you what
all these meant but either way I
wouldn't REM I wouldn't memorize it I
couldn't think of that word see how
stupid I am I wouldn't I obviously was
to figure that out there's two doors but
let me see what's in this one what's
going on here
what's going on nope not today with this
seeker rifle a screw that I already have
a seat I need a store like real bad now
that I have all these different guns I
have to carry around all this different
ammo oh what a pain so inconvenient like
Nami
hell haha couldn't get through that door
to get to me eh oh you're so wimpy oh ah
panda bass back is that thing floating I
swear it was floating there review the
footage enhance enhance who's floating
elsewhere ah ha ha
what the hell is this
okay it's a little kid it looks like
she's wearing a bride's gown
why I'm starting to think these
Unitologist were crazier than they look
and that kinda damn crazy all this
writing looks pretty crazy too
all right I'll leave it on that crazy
note that's all the time I got for this
episode but man he's gone too crazy
anyway thank you guys so much for
watching and as always we'll see you you
in the next part
bye-bye